ich ärgere mich über die
Ladenschlussgesetze in Deutschland und
zwar tue ich das aus aktuellem Anlass
denn wir haben in diesen Tagen 25 Jahre
Reform des deutschen landschlussgesetzes
vor genau 25 Jahren hat der Bundestag
entschieden die Läden in Deutschland
müssen nicht mehr um 18 Uhr 30 sondern
sie dürfen gnädigerweise schon um 20 Uhr
zu machen und seither gibt es eine
gesetzesflut in Deutschland weil auch
die Bundesländer inzwischen zuständig
sind wir haben etwa 4 bis 500
Gesetzesverordnung allein zum
Ladenschluss und der Ladenschluss ist
völlig wirr und lässt sich im Alltag es
gibt ausnahmenregelungen für Tankstellen
für Flughäfen für Apotheken für
Blumenläden in jedem Bundesland ist es
wiederum ein bisschen anders deswegen
fordere ich schafft sie einfach alle ab
diese Gesetze das wäre ein Gnadenakt für
unseren leidenden Einzelhandel der am
Ende der corona-pandemie wirklich schwer
gelitten hat es wäre ein
gerechtigkeitsakt den der
Konkurrenzsituation zum online diese
gegenüber denn der untereinander der
läuft einfach 24/7 durch es wäre eine
Wohltat für unsere Innenstädte wenn dort
auch mal einen Laden bis um 9 Uhr
aufmachen könnte und es wäre eine
praktische Lebenshilfe für Millionen von
gerade jungen älter die Arbeiten und
abends nach dem Beruf noch in ein völlig
überfüllten Supermarkt hetzen um noch
die Milch zu kaufen also mein Appell an
dieser Stelle Schluss mit dem
Ladenschluss
Wolfram das ist absolut richtig ich
wünschte mir dass einer der drei
Kandidaten in diesem Triel das so
formuliert hätte aber warum tun sie es
nicht weil sie wissen aha wir kriegen
die Kirchen an die Baki wir kriegen die
Gewerkschaften an der Backe alles was
Sie gesagt haben ist richtig alles ist
logisch aber ich glaube nicht dass ein
Politiker den Mut hätte das sozusagen
die Kirchen beispielsweise ich bin mein
Leben lang ohne zu fragen um 10 Uhr im
Kindergottesdienst passiert weil man
dahin zu gehen hatte ich bin der Meinung
wenn die Kirche sagt die Läden müssen zu
sein und wenn jemand nur deswegen in die
Kirche geht weil er nicht einkaufen
gehen kann dann müsste die Kirche auf
den gerne verzichten können weil wir
sagen der würde normalerweise einkaufen
gehen weil er nicht weiß wohin er soll
geht er in die Kirche das ist doch
Quatsch und ich habe in Amerika ohne
dass ich hier klugscheiße über
Jahrzehnte hinweg überhaupt nicht mehr
daran gedacht haben die Läden auf oder
nicht du bist einfach wenn du was
gebraucht hast dahin marschiert und da
saßen keine verzweifelten Verkäuferin
Sonntag gehört die Motive oder was ist
da bei uns alles auch gab dieser Anzug
Kleider I can work aber das sind
grundsätzlich völlig andere
Gesichtspunkte es gibt eine Werbung in
Amerika da ist eine erkennbar 70-Jährige
Bedienung die sagt finally reinwerke I
can work again das Arthritis Mittel
hilft dir also sie kann wieder die
Tablets tragen dann sagt unser einer aus
der als Erziehung die wir kommen um
Gottes Willen bleibt zu Hause und wo wo
hört es auf also dass man sagen kann
jeder soll so lange arbeiten wie er will
egal ob er Arthritis hat oder nicht
jeder soll sein Laden aufmachen wann er
will und da kommt wieder die
Ordnungspolitik ins Spiel was wollen wir
und das sind für mich politische
Sachverhalte die ich gerne von einem
Politiker erklärt haben möchte oder B
gefordert haben möchte wir sitzen hier
und sagen ja das muss doch mal einer
machen und keiner wird es machen warum
nicht sinn würde es aber machen doch ich
glaube wenn wir eine Ampelkoalition
bekommen wird des Ladenschlussgesetz in
Deutschland liberalisiert ja ja das bin
ich mal eine Hoffnung und nach dem
heutigen Appell sowieso was hat er mit
politischer Führung zu den führung
bedeutet der Priorität ja da muss
manches was wichtig was wichtig ist
getrennt werden von dem von dem weniger
Wiking und ich finde das wichtigste hier
in der eben im bei diesem
ladenschutzgesetz ist nicht Verweigerung
der
kundenzentrierung ja Kunde ist König und
der Ladestand
ist eine antiquierte
vor reflektiert eine antiquierte
Vorstellung
reflektiert eine antiquierte Vorstellung
von von der einer
Dienstleistungsgesellschaft ja der Kunde
ist König und das ist ja im
Online-Handel ja und wenn ich jetzt sehe
ich bin dasselbe interessierte diverse
Online
hier Shops wenn ich sehe mit mit welcher
Freude die jungen Leute daran arbeiten
dass alles zu präsentieren dasselbe kann
man kann man im stationären Handel auch
machen und wenn heute über die
Konkurrenz mit dem Ort zwischen
Online-Handel und stationären Handel
wäre gesprochen wird das quasi da der
Online-Handel einer Verödung der
Innenstädte führen würde weil dann eben
viele Geschäfte sich doch deutlich mehr
lohnen würde das einzige Mittel daraus
zu kommen ist genauer das was du
forderst Ladenschluss Weg alles auf
alles mit guter Laune und die Leute
bummeln dann herum bis 9 Uhr Abends ja
und fühlen sich endlich mal die Kunden
ich finde es ich sehe gerade selber wie
gefangen nicht in unseren
Reglements bin denn die komplette
Freigabe sozusagen jeder kann öffnen
wann er will habe ich mir in der
drastischen Form noch nie vorgestellt
finde ich ihn interessanten finde ich
ein interessanten Punkt mich beschleicht
so eine leichte Sorge ob das nicht gut
ist für die großen stärkeren und
schlecht für die Kleinen
ganz kleinen warum
wir sind in new yorkong London
aber
ich würde sagen lasst doch die Kunden
entscheiden also ich würde für eine
Novellierung des Gesetzes sein aber
somit Probezeit also ein Jahr ist ein
Untersuchungszeitraum und dann gucken
wir uns an ob sozusagen die komplette
Offenlegung und und
eröffnungsmöglichkeit stärker ist und
größeren impact auf die Gesellschaft und
die Wirtschaft als das Achtung als das
Ritual ich finde es eigentlich ganz gut
dass Sonntag nicht die gleiche Hölle los
ist wie Montag und Mittwoch
aber anders
müssen
die hässliche Fratze des regulieren
aber der erste Satz ist nicht gefällt
eine leichte Sorge
lass uns mal ausprobieren ja da spricht
machen staatliche Regulierung
das war jetzt nicht irgendwie vier gegen
ein okay ihr habt mich überzeugt
bei einer Sache bei springen ich bin
zwar ja auch sehr ich sehr für den
freien Markt aber mit einer Sache ist in
Amerika ist das System ja auch anders da
müssen die Menschen ja auch wirklich
noch viel viel stärker arbeiten gehen
als bei uns ich liebe den American Dream
den American way of thinking aber ich
finde manchmal schon ganz gut das ist
bei uns nicht ganz so krass ist und ich
frage mich dann halt schon was ist dann
mit den Leuten macht ich meine wenn man
in einem hoch dotierten Job irgendwie
vom Montag bis Sonntag arbeitet dann
sage ich mir immer na ja die Leute
werden gut entlohnt aber was würde es
dann machen mit den Mitarbeitern die ihr
schon für geringe Löhne arbeiten jetzt
habt ihr ja euren Spaß gehabt mit mir
weil ihr gesagt habt der Kunde der Kunde
der Kunde aber ist denn mit dem
Mitarbeiter
dieser wissen dass sie in einem
Dienstleistungsbetrieb ist ein Hotel wie
hast du doch auch nicht sagen ich mache
die Bar um 11 Uhr zu weil der Bericht
jetzt ja
das ist doch nicht die einzige
Dienstleistungsbranche hier es gibt halt
immer solche so wie bei Hartz IV die
einen wollen raus die anderen richten
sich ein bei Verkäuferinnen wir kennen
das alles aus den Kaufhäusern die gerade
so die Flucht ergreifen wenn du eine
Frage stellst und anderen die kommt eben
sagt kann ich Ihnen helfen es ist die
persönliche attitude des Einzelnen und
es gibt Verkäuferin wo man sagen kann
danke danke hier will und ich gehe noch
mal kurz ins Lager gucken und ich habe
ihre Größe wenn sie nicht da ist halt es
gibt solche und ein Wohnungs um
Entschuldigung dass ich gestört habe das
ist das
menschliche Bundesländer da dürfen die
Bäcker am Sonntag nur so und so viel
Stunden aufmachen die Kaffee ist aber
den ganzen Tag jetzt erklären sich die
Bäcker zu speisen Anbieter und wollen
das vor Gericht eingeladen ist prüfen
Richter ob ein belegtes Brötchen eine
Speise ist oder nicht und einen Kaffee
ähnliches Geschäft und das ist doch
alles ab sofort
also in der corona-zeit nur eine
Fortschreibung dieses Unsinns das quasi
der Uhren der Uhrenladen auf der einen
Seite der Straße erschließen musste aber
der Bücher verkauft Buchladen auf der
anderen Seite offen hat also sozusagen
das heißt aus dem verrückten
Ladenschlussgesetz hat sich die absurde
Corona genau
die auch schon bis Mitternacht auf haben
ja und da findest du auch gut gelaunte
ähm Käufer
AFD 10 nur zu der Film im Alter dann
zwei Stunden Verdienst aber es ist eine
Sache abzuschließen und sagen ich bin
weg
aber würde da nicht andere
Dienstleistungsbranche wie zum Beispiel
der Friseursalon und Co noch viel mehr
helfen also für mich wäre das eine große
Erleichterung wenn ich hier nach 8:15
Uhr zum
Friseurladen
schneiden dürfen das wäre natürlich
schon also ich war mal in Hongkong und
Mitternacht bei einem Friseur es war
außer unterhaltsam und die Vorstellung
des ein Staat herkommt und den Menschen
dem Friseur und dem Kunden vorschreibt
du darfst das nur zu bestimmten Uhrzeit
die ist doch absolut stellt euch mal vor
wir würden das im Internet machen weil
aus irgendwelchen Gründen wird der
Meinung sind es muss Stunden geben genau
[Musik]